je vais revoir sonia grande un soldat
verdun c'était ton amour de jeunesse
regarde là on a une autre photo de sonia
grandin regarde elle et elle est encore
allée lé lé bal est là elle est là sonia
je suis en bas à droite mal à concevoir
un magnifique tu avais la coupe de m et
sonia grondin je sais qu'ils étaient
très amoureux est là avec mes la rélève
la bourdelle de quel jeu je crois que
c'est assez
c'est l'amour de l'école primaire voilà
c'est l'amour de l'école primaire que
sur laquelle on focalise et on croit
qu'un moment elle va dire oui a dit non
elle n'avait même jamais répondu elle va
peut-être te réponds que ce soir c'était
là combien de temps à wayne 35 ans 30
ans 35 ans 35 ans est bien à magog elle
est là ce soir
applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
sonia est quel bonheur de voir elle est
toujours belle est la page ali baddou
fille dans l'attentât
je vais faire une gobain sa note
emmanuel thomas c'est pas très classe et
que madoff connue a dit oui walt mal
partout vous êtes magnifique sur
l'arrière on fait tout ce qu'on fait
dans la discrétion
je suis préparatrice en pharmacie
d'accord avant le talent vous avez suivi
quoi vous saviez qu'il était amoureux de
vous pas oui bien sûr
c'était o'dea là c'était pas votre
délire à l'époque
malheureusement non enfin de sa décharge
je sais ce que ça peut être une jolie
fille avec la lourdeur du gars qui
essaie à chaque fois mais j'essayais
gentiment toujours pas ce que parce que
voilà j'ai jamais les paroles ou et à
chaque fois on à la piscine ensemble
j'essaie d'être avec elle à chaque fois
j'essaie de mettre à côté d'elle et
jamais elle maréval est méchamment elle
a l'air maintenant telle marche n'aurait
pas dû vous habitez ou sonia habite à
chauny d'accord c'est dans le 02 02 vous
êtes mariés oui marié marié wi fi des
[Rires]
pas divorcer du tout je suis divorcé et
remarié
non elles ont été appelées entre le nom
mois avant qu'on voit le gagnant de koh
lanta
j'aimerais alors qu'on se dise que ce
soir on est dans une ambiance book on
est haut rang on est dans les années 80
est ce que tu attends je sais ce que tu
vas faire à ce genre on va mettre une
musique / scorpions steele aux gars que
tu sais quand même que je suis devenu dj
quand j'avais 11 ans parce qu'aucune
fille voulait jamais danse avec les
pinceaux fois réaliser ton rêve tu vas
invités
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
la version lama début de boom
c'est à dire on n'ose pas trop ouais
c'est ça via la version au boom
oui à la version quand même choisi la
une la deux la croix 35 ans tu choisis
oui ne vais pas dans l'embarras non et
voilà que voilà
c'est bon
allez fais tu te lances la tactique
sahara
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu un regret
vous dire j'aurais non je dois répondre
à cette nuit je crois que c'est ça
ils souhaitent faire de peine ah ah ah
non non mais n'en est pas du tout sur le
bal mois moi si j'avais une meuf corps
et pêchu c'est vrai tu sais que ça me
fait moi aussi mais voilà